بالحب والصبر عاشت الملكه القرينه الملك
بطانيه تشارلز الثالث سيده قصر بوكينغهام
الجديده كامله
وصلت في النهايه الى القبول من الناس ومن
الملك الراحله اليزابيث التي باركت وصولها
الوشيك الى لقب الملكه القرين وذلك قبيله
وفاتها باشهر كانت الملكه القرينه حبا
قديما لتشارلز وهي تعرضت لاقصى حمل علنيه
ضدها فهي المتهمه الاولى والاخيره بالنسبه
لكثيرين ومنذ سنوات بانها قضت على الحياه
الزوجيه التشارلز وديانا كامله دخلت القصر
بعد ديانه في عام 2005 راقبت الصحافه
مظهرها وشخصيتها الخجوله العائله المالكه
لم تفضلها كزوجه لملك المستقبل لكن
العلاقه انتصرت في النهايه تمضي الايام
وهي تجتاز العواصف التي لحقت بها بعد
زواجها من ولي العهد لتعزز مكانتها
بالاسره الحاكمه
كما ستجلس الى جانب الملك تشارلز يوم
تتويجه في السادس من مايو المقبل
[موسيقى]